those are enormous Jesus Christ I wore
gingka jeans for an entire week and this
is what happened
chinko Dean's came out mid-to-late 90s
they fit you normally at the very top
and then they get incredibly baggy at
the bottom
I always thought Jenko jeans were really
interesting and something drew me to
them and I could never wear them because
I went to a Catholic middle school where
I had to wear a uniform it was a weird
feeling at first whitter lee couldn't
believe how large they were it felt like
you were wearing a denim comforter I got
used to the swishing noise and the very
slight breeze that were to go up my legs
the pockets were interesting meat
pockets they were great I mean they were
relatively functional you could fit
anything you could probably fit a small
child and just put my entire laptop in
the back pocket of my pants shoes it was
just bad the pandas are dragging when
they get wet like it's you're wearing a
puddle well my pants when I got stuck on
something my pants got caught on sore
grapes
I avoided escalators at all cost they
terrify me to begin with
wearing drink goes on top of that
there's no chance the initial rush of
wearing the pants has worn out and
people were really blatantly staring at
me when I woke up on Wednesday I just
decided I was gonna go for it if people
are gonna look at me on the streets I
might as well give him something to look
at so I put on a bucket hat and a
Crystal Pepsi t-shirt and I just went
all out with my 90's look so pretty
liberating it was great I really enjoyed
it actually
I just really didn't care what anyone
else thought anymore so I was feeling
great after Wednesday and I wake up
Thursday and I'm talking to my
girlfriend before we leave the apartment
to go to work and she tells me that she
has a work happy hour and then
immediately remembered that I was
wearing Jenko jeans all week and
immediately disinvited me my girlfriend
just takes me and I seriously did not
show up to for work at the hour I
realized that the experiment had gotten
a little out of control
I was happy to be wearing them for one
last day thanks so much yeah I was
reflecting on the entire week my friend
got tickets for the Big East tournament
it was the celebration of getting
through it all it felt like they were
throwing a party for me even though
there was basketball game going on then
I realized coming out of masses Square
Garden I had to take escalators I get to
the top of escalator and I just I jumped
I was okay it was definitely like a
culmination of the whole week it was
this celebration of getting through at
all I would recommend anybody to wear
jingle jeans for a week I think it's a
great exercise in stripping away or you
go and really just trying something
different and living in someone else's
pants